this is my Jon Snow
look by the way when my hair's just
right okay we got a
slide so at the dawn of the 21st century
uh I was dissatisfied with my home
country the US did not fit my values and
the customer service was terrible like I
just wanted like a Vodaphone kind of
level and it wasn't even close so I
thought maybe I'm in the wrong country I
looked around the world and really
places weren't much better so I was like
there's something really strange about
this government industry that it's the
largest sector in the global economy but
the biggest company posts like
staggering losses year after year and
the worst companies
horror and so that was the puzzle in the
early 2000s most Industries are
constantly innovating and improving but
most governments are barely innovating
and they sometimes even go backwards so
a lot of people look at government
through the lens of um is it moral or
does it represent me and I take a
different view I say drop that and just
look at government as an industry so
what do we see first the firms are
massive and we know what that means for
Innovation and second the barrier to
entry it's not just high it's like
undefined you're like dereferencing a
null pointer like there's not a process
that's known and then the cost of
switching providers like moving between
countries is really high getting lower
year after year but still really high
and so from this angle this kind of cuts
through all these other views and just
says we have an industry that's a cartel
of huge companies that have local
monopolies and high customer lockin like
of course this shitty service of course
the there's no innovation like the
problem is not philosophical it's
structural and this view also suggests
an answer right we they got this Legacy
industry doing a crappy job how do we
fix it with startups with competition so
you know now I'd reduce this problem of
finding a home country for myself to
something simple we just have to change
the world so that people can create new
jurisdictions they can create cities and
countries like they start companies
today simple right I mean not easy but
simple so my first iteration was seting
the idea was that by building
communities on the ocean we'd open a new
frontier where we could create new
societies new
jurisdictions then the barrier to entry
might be as low as a cruise ship not
because the high seas are Lawless I'm so
tired of that that's not how it works it
actually works in a really cool way
where each ship registers with a country
f their flag and it's under their
jurisdiction almost like a floating
Embassy the country is franchising their
sovereignty to the vessel like which is
amazing it's very Network stady and
because it's a virtual Association in
order to have some level of autonomy you
just have to find one country anywhere
in the world that's willing to create a
custom flag for you that wants to serve
this new market so I wrote a book on SE
stading in 2004 um with little with
pearl scripts so you could comment on
every on every paragraph uh and then in
2007 Peter teal funded me to start the
first competitive governance nonprofit
the SE setting Institute and we reached
millions of people with the idea of
building new societies um including some
of the audience and speakers here today
and we got the message out so well that
we were even Mark mocked by talk shows
which like now I wear is this total
badge of honor a Haven as connected to
land as Libertarians are to
reality and you know he wasn't all wrong
um after starting the Institute my
partner and I running it knew that we
needed more than a nonprofit and some
renderings we needed to
build so we in 2011 we started working
on a medical tourism cruise ship company
which we thought was promising but now
let's go back meanwhile Dubai pioneered
the modern Zone in 20
4 they wanted to create a financial
center and they knew that their
homegrown Sharia law was not a good
supportive tech for that
product now laws most people don't
realize that law is open source meaning
it's published freely it's available
it's copiable so Dubai forked London's
code base they copied it and modified it
for their own uses leaving it in English
with the the rest of their laws in
Arabic and they even created their own
courts and brought in uh UK judges who
are experience with this Co base then in
2009 e comist Paul RoR now a Nobel
laurat brought his take on the idea and
his analysis of why expanding the
traditional idea of zones to become
Charter cities would be an incredible
tool for development many technical
details to be worked out but those of us
who are already starting to pursue the
think can already tell that there's no
roadblock there's no impediment other
than a failure of
imagination like Dubai RoR zones would
set their own commercial law but in his
model uh rather than being set up and
run by the country as Dubai did it was
set up and run by some uh guar nation
that had good laws and high investor
trust a brilliant group in Honduras saw
that potential this idea and they they
created the first real world program
unlike rors concept these zones would be
developed in a public private
partnership with a company working with
Honduras as the host country I heard
about this in 2011 was like holy crap
like wow like this this stuff is real we
can like create a new jurisdiction on
land where things are easier to build
and so my co-founder and I pivoted to
Charter cities uh after a year of work
and the world's first mou for a charter
City with Honduras we realized in 2012
that we were just too early like
Honduras had changed their constitution
but they didn't have any budget yet like
this was like a Google 20% project like
kind of nights and weekends like side
hustle and so you know it was not going
to happen soon we figured it would take
years for them to get this program and
so you know we wound things up and did
other
things in the years after that starting
in 2012 to
2017 Bitcoin started showering wealth on
people who were highly highly value
aligned and this has actually turned out
to be critical in my fund uh the
majority of investment dollars comes
from crypto so really important
enabler then in 2017 The Zeta program
gave initial approval to Honduras
prospera which you seen and heard about
here like after 15 years a startup city
was finally
happening so I saw this as it's gotten
real you know we're going from dreamers
to doers this is actually happening
there's going to be whole new industry
around these ideas so I started work on
Poma Capital which is the first Charter
City investment
fund we closed in 2019 with some
incredible backers including the
Visionary who brought all of us here
together today and we fund companies
that are actually building like I love
that I finally get to show videos of
like dirt like real dirt like dirt is
exciting dirt is not a rendering dirt is
not an idea or a metaphor dirt is real
um and you've heard about prosper and
practice so I'll show you a few
others when I close my eyes sometimes I
imagine a magical Sunset against the Sol
weight of greenhouse full of fresh
fruits and a light cool bleed against a
sparkling Pond full of
tilapia I imagine my son playing in
Green Grass and my family sitting down
to a healthy meal in a home I can call
my own in a community I help to build so
that's small farm cities we're just
turning empty land in Africa into
profitable farming villages with microG
grid infrastructure and affordable
housing now itana in Nigeria has been
approved for the first digital free zone
in Africa maybe in the world this is
like a new type of special economic zone
that adds incorporation Banking and
other features
and they're building a district for
Builders where 3,000 people will enjoy
co-living
co-working restaurants and nature within
the 150 square kilm Ley free zone which
includes the largest refinery in
[Music]
Africa real
dirt and in palao our company Metropolis
just got the green light from the
president Senate and Congress shout out
to elae over there to create an offshore
corporate registry where you can
incorporate with the laws of Delaware or
Singapore or Taiwan remember laws are
open source there's nothing to stop a
country from importing the laws and
precedence of another country like a
software Library so you'll be able to
incorporate offshore with standard
documents or Port an existing company to
palow like moving data centers keeping
all of your
documents and this is so real that this
week I am going to prosper to get my
jeans edited with a treatment only
available there like that is real really
really real so join us if you want to
learn more you can find my podcasts and
interviews follow us on our socials
portfolio socials and my DMs are
open